hey everyone coming to you with some
really sad news today earlier on I read
that Michael Gambon who famously played
Alba's Dumbledore for the majority of
the Harry Potter films has passed away
at the age of 82. we are devastated to
announce the loss of Sir Michael Gambon
said the statement issued on behalf of
his wife Anne and Son Fergus by
publicist Claire Dobbs it added that he
died peacefully in hospital after a bout
with pneumonia with the pair at his
bedside his family also added we ask
that you respect our privacy at this
painful time and thank you for your
messages of support and love for those
unaware Gambon took over the role of
Dumbledore after the death of Richard
Harris who portrayed the wise old wizard
in the Philosopher's Stone and Chamber
of Secrets and to take over the role he
certainly did and while the two men may
have portrayed Dumbledore in their own
unique ways both were incredibly
effective leaving their mark on the
Harry Potter franchise for all of
eternal born on October 19 1940 in
Dublin Ireland Michael Gambon showed an
early inclination towards the Arts he
left school at the age of 15 and went on
to become a successful engineer however
the Allure of the theater proved
irresistible and to Gambon soon embarked
on professional acting career he joined
the prestigious National Theater in
London's Old Vic as one of its founding
members in 1962
collaborating with legendary figures
like Lawrence Olivier Derek Jacoby and
Maggie Smith Gambon developed his craft
and gained prominence on the stage
throughout his illustrious career Gambon
amassed numerous Awards and honors he
received three Olivier Awards and two
critic Circle Theater awards for his
remarkable stage performances on the
screen Gambon was honored with four
British Academy of film and television
Arts Awards additionally he won two
ensemble cast Screen Actors Guild Awards
for his roles in Gosford Park and The
King's Speech in 1998 Gambon was
knighted for his immense contributions
to the world of drama but it wasn't just
contributions to the world of drama that
Gambon deserved to be knighted for I
think I can speak for everyone when I
see the Gambon played an integral part
of so many people's childhoods bringing
the iconic role of Dumbledore to life
it's tough getting older and seeing our
childhood Heroes passing away but but
just like Hagrid and Robbie Coltrane
gambon's contributions to the world of
theater will live forever